things people have yelled at me for on
the internet as a dietitian number one
saying that seed oils aren't complete
poison number two eating unhealthy food
or really anything that's not green
juice salad or avocado toast folks
having an occasional pizza night doesn't
mean I have a jug diet number three
saying that you probably need more than
1200 calories a day for the vast
majority of women young or older 1200
calories is nowhere near enough number
four if I even so much as hint at the
fact that it's possible for a larger
body folk to be metabolically healthy
one of my goals on this app is to really
invite everyone to re-examine their
biases on that and finally when I say
that diets usually don't work I talk
about why weight loss is so hard to
encourage dieters to exercise some
self-empathy and it demonstrates some of
the key factors in what they lead to
weight regain not to dismiss people's
desire to lose weight